[Musik]
alles was wir kaufen wird mit dem LKW
transportiert kein Essen ohne Fahrer
aber Anerkennung fehlt in Bezug auf
Wertschätzung würde ich mal sagen 0
80.000 Fahrer fehlen in Deutschland
manche Trucker wollen gar nicht mehr in
Deutschland bist du da die
Anführungsstriche der letzte bambel
obwohl wir die ganze Wirtschaft am
Laufen halten
der Fahrermangel nimmt zu osteuropäische
Unternehmen springen ein Ausbeutung
steigt
[Musik]
Halle an der Saale hier wollen sie den
Fahrermangel an der Wurzel bekämpfen
indem Sie welche ausbilden
heute die grundveraufgabe 20 Meter
rückwärts an der Rampe durchführen ja
das weißt du ja kannst dich einsetzen
und dann beginnen
auf geht's
und langsam weiter wunderbar er ist im
ersten Ausbildungsjahr
jawohl wunderbar und weiter
Google rechten Spiegel nach seiner
Ausbildung wird er einen Arbeitsvertrag
nach Tarif bekommen und Stopp Stopp
ist annähernd also so wäre das
prüfungstechnisch bestanden
[Musik]
war das alles noch ein bisschen die
fernfahrerromantik was jetzt nicht mehr
der Fall ist jetzt ist Zeitdruck enorm
auf die Fahrer wird immer mehr abgewälzt
und es hat auch anders Substanz aber
jetzt ich sage mal ich möchte jetzt
nicht mehr machen weil ich das
eigentlich warm macht mir immer noch
Spaß aber der Stress brauche
[Musik]
Schüler dagegen schreckt das nicht
das macht mir Spaß wenn ich lange
unterwegs
sein Kollege Rack mojon ist schon im
dritten Lehrjahr er fährt den
Betonmischer eine große Herausforderung
auf der Baustelle warten sie bereits
also alle Kollegen sind häufig
werden wir nicht etwas verstanden haben
oder wenn wir etwas Probleme haben
sie erklären uns ja
bis jetzt kommen wir sehr gut klar
wir sind in der geduldig
[Musik]
RAG mojion ist ein Hoffnungsträger für
das Logistikunternehmen Papenburg auf
dem Hof stehen neue und alte
Zugmaschinen manche warten auf Reparatur
für andere gibt es schlicht keine Fahrer
im Unternehmen ist Angela Papenburg
zuständig fürs Personal
Logistikbranche ist schon seit Jahren
schwierig es fehlt einfach insgesamt am
Fahrpersonal letztes Jahr hatten wir
auch mal eine Zeit gehabt so 15 LKWs am
Tag einfach stehen mussten und das
wollen wir natürlich vermeiden
eigentlich soll das so nicht sein
vor einer Woche war Angela Papenburg
noch in Usbekistan
Personalgespräche von ihren
Auszubildenden zum Berufskraftfahrer ist
nur einer deutscher die anderen 42 sind
Usbeken auf jeden Fall wird es in der
Zukunft einfach auch der einzige Weg
sein um alle Ausbildungsplätze
besetzen zu können
hier in der Disposition sind alle LKW
auf den Bildschirmen sichtbar auch der
von rakoion er ist zurück auf den Bauhof
oben auf der Plattform sitzt der
Anlagenfahrer er teilt die betonladung
zu
wann kann ich wlane ich mich schon
ladebereit
keine Unterschiede solange jeder seine
Arbeit macht bin ich dann zufrieden
Fulda der Fahrer dieses LKW macht seit
mehr als 50 Jahren seine Arbeit seit
Jahrzehnten on the road und immer noch
voll dabei Udo Horn
die familienspedition für die er
arbeitet ist spezialisiert auf Italien
Transporte
für Italien
keiner der Fahrer fuhr so oft über die
Alpen wie Udo Italien Verkehr seit 1976
unkraut vergeht nicht
vor drei Jahren haben André Dietzel und
seine Frau die Leitung der Spedition
übernommen
auch sie haben einen wachsendes
Personalproblem
etliche ihrer Fahrer sind schon über 60
ja man macht sich absolut Sorgen weil
der Fahrermarkt halt das nicht zulässt
das neue neue dazukommen meine Frachten
sind da und die müssen gefahren werden
und wenn die Fahrer aufhören und weniger
werden dann ja kriegen wir Probleme
Fernfahrer gesucht
Speditionen arbeiten mit allen Mitteln
um ihren personalhunger zu stillen
Fahrer werden abgeworben an den
Parkplätzen es gibt auch sogar Prämien
die anderen Speditionen ihren Fahrern
bieten wenn Sie andere Fahrer abwerben
ganz anständig ist es nicht aber am Ende
des Tages muss man auch seine offenen
Stellen besetzen
wie jede Woche macht Udo Strecke
fünf Tage unterwegs
dafür am Wochenende zu Hause
meine Frau die kennen das nicht anders
die habe ich 1978 kennengelernt da habe
ich schon gefahren und
ich habe ja halt die Wahl gelassen ob
sie das mitmacht oder nicht
dann haben wir geheiratet
die kleine Reinigungsfirma seiner Frau
das reicht nicht
zwei Monate hatte der 69-Jährige mal
aufgehört zu arbeiten nun sitzt er
wieder auf dem Bock
[Musik]
ich mag nicht alleine
würde es schon eng weil es ist ja die
Preise sind ja in letzter Zeit
regelrecht durch die Decke geschossen
etwa 2600 Euro brutto verdient der
monatlich im Sommer wird er 70 dann wird
er wohl endgültig aufhören
30.000 Kraftfahrer gehen jährlichen
Rente aber nur 15.000 fangen neu an der
Personalmangel wird von Jahr zu Jahr
größer die Arbeitsbelastung sei in
letzter Zeit noch mal deutlich mehr
geworden erzählt Udo besonders sei das
bei Lieferungen an den Einzelhandel zu
spüren das sollte ich sogar die Rücken
des Plastik von den Paletten schneiden
ich sage Leute geht's eigentlich noch
was bin ich eigentlich bin ich hier der
Lagerarbeiter der lagerfuzzi oder bin
ich Fahrer das ganze hat nur noch mit
Ausbeutung zu tun mit Wertschätzung hat
das gar nichts mehr zu tun
an manchen Tagen staut sich der
LKW-Verkehr schon 25 km vor der
österreichischen Grenze heute hat Udo
Glück da stehen wir hier stundenlang
ja da kommt keiner und fragte mal
wie geht's brauchst dir irgendwas oder
so da kriegt man höchstens gesagt hätte
in der Schule aufgepasst und jetzt was
gescheites gelernt willst du nicht hier
stehen müssen
ca 80% aller Güter werden in Deutschland
auf der Straße transportiert 8% sind es
auf der Schiene
es wird abends
einen der Stellplätze in Kiefersfelden
für die Nacht kann ergattern wenig
später wird der Parkplatz voll sein
fehlt noch das Abendessen
für mich macht sie insofern sind wenn
ich so oder alleine unterwegs bin ich
mag auch nicht alleine irgendwann Essen
das ist weiß nicht
Raststätten sind ihm außerdem zu teuer
dann lieber den mitgebrachten
Fleischkäse vom Discounter
der Feierabend eines Fernfahrers
Hertha noch trifft es die Fahrer am
Rastplatz Gräfenhausen bei Darmstadt
Mitte März beginnt ein fahrerstreik
verschiedene Gewerkschaften unterstützen
ihn
[Musik]
60 Lkw-Fahrer die für eine polnische
Spedition Arbeiten sind im Arbeitskampf
die Fahrer kommen aus Usbekistan und
Georgien
Regina
wir streiten weil wir nicht bezahlt
werden und als Menschen werden wir auch
nicht respektiert
ich arbeite seit zwei Monaten für die
Firma bin zum ersten Mal in Europa Geld
habe ich überhaupt noch nicht bekommen
bei jedem ist die Situation etwas anders
einig sind sie sich erst wieder zu
fahren wenn alle bezahlt wurden
kakabiri kommt aus Georgien 80 Euro ist
sein Tageslohn
seit vier Monaten bin ich auf der Straße
letztes Jahr war ich sogar elf Monate
ununterbrochen unterwegs
schlafen essen alles im LKW dauerhaft
leben auf vier Quadratmetern seine
Familie in Georgien ist von ihm abhängig
sie wartet auf das Geld aber die Firma
zahlt nicht
ich habe nur 4000 von meinen 8000 Euro
Lohn bis jetzt bekommen
die polnische Spedition sagt die Löhne
seien vertragsgemäß bezahlt worden
Gewerkschafter haben da Zweifel
sie werden ausgenutzt weil es ja tausend
von Kilometern
und dann sagen hier entweder ich bekomme
mein Geld oder ich war ne das hier ist
ein guter Verzweiflung und das ja auch
ausgenutzt wird auch von deutschen
Hersteller das sind Subunternehmer vom
Subunternehmer vom zugunternehmer und
den letzten der muss dann billigsten
fahren und die Leute die in dem letzte
Kette drin sind die werden auch als
wenigstens bezahlt oder
gar nicht
gelegentlich halten deutsche Lkw-Fahrer
um die Streitenden zu unterstützen
Solidarität auch Anwohner kommen zur
Raststätte wollen helfen
solche Aktion hier auf dem Parkplatz ist
bestimmt schwierig
das Essen zuzubereiten und es ist nur
eine Kleinigkeit
die Fahrer aus Georgien und Usbekistan
halten die LKW der polnischen Spedition
als Pfand für ihren Lohn noch ist die
Situation friedlich
in Halle auf dem Bauhof warte Track
mojon darauf Beton zu laden um in
Deutschland zu arbeiten musste er vorher
ausreichende Sprachkenntnisse nachweisen
weil Berlin Zentrum es gibt eine
Sprachzentrum die Name ist
da hatte ich ein Jahr Deutsch gelernt am
Anfang war ein bisschen schwierig
aber
was sage ich
kann man lernen
für junge Usbeken wie rakoion sind die
Deutschen Löhne ein überzeugendes
Argument ihre Heimat zu verlassen
also bei uns ist bisschen schwieriger
alles hier
wir haben
Arbeit mangelhaft deswegen kommen viele
Leute hier in Europa wegen verdienen ja
sein usbekischer Kollege ist noch dabei
den LKW-Führerschein zu machen
Fahrstunde
beobachte langsam langsam langsam gucken
guck mal da kommt der kontrollieren ja
in der Firma und in der Fahrschule
nennen ihn alle Sherlock
mein echter Name ist
und hier ist meine Name links ja wir
blinken links sie haben gerade gehört
wie die die Familie
und deswegen haben die alle so
Spitznamen für Computer mit klar
die Teilnehmer auch
und da ist der Hauptsache wir müssen das
muss funktionieren ja alles gut
ich fühle mich
in Usbekistan war er Englischlehrer in
Deutschland wird er Lkw-Fahrer
Feierabend für Rack Mojang die Firma hat
den usbekischen Auszubildenden Wohnungen
organisiert gelegentlich kochen sie
zusammen so wie von zu Hause gewohnt ich
hatte in Usbekistan viel mal Lamm und
der Rind geschlachtet
beim Schlachten muss man immer
ihre Freizeit hier verbringen Sie
gemeinsam mit anderen Auszubildenden
eine Ersatzfamilie fern der Heimat
zum Beispiel wenn ich heute koche
Morgen hat meine Mitarbeiter dadurch
von seinem Vater gelernt heute gibt es
das Nationalgericht pilo
mein Papa
er ist auch nicht immer zu Hause wann er
zu Hause ist macht für uns
dann essen wir zusammen
und das ist unser Schlafzimmer und das
ist mein Freund wird und das ist meine
in der Dreizimmerwohnung leben vier
Auszubildende zusammen sie sind zwischen
20 und 25 Jahre alt das ist um sehr
freundlich die Firma investiert einiges
in die zukünftigen Fahrer
andere Ort hören oder andere Unterkunft
finden und dann müssen wir bezahlen aber
jetzt nicht
jetzt alles kostenlos
[Musik]
der Tisch ist gedeckt wie zu Hause in
Usbekistan
ich mit meinen Kollegen zusammen
ich genau mein Familie ja ja Heimweh
immer dabei
ja weil wir sind vor zehn Monaten
gekommen hier
ist
ein Problem für uns
obwohl sie als Auszubildende maximal
1050 € brutto verdienen unterstützen sie
ihre Familien wenn ich bis hin geht
übrig habe dann schicke ich nach Heimat
bei mir auch so
[Musik]
promon Pro 4 oder 3 Monaten 200 oder 150
Euro
. alle hier wollen nach der Ausbildung
noch zwei drei Jahre bei Papenburg
weiterarbeiten sagen sie für die Firma
sind sie unentbehrlich
in Gräfenhausen spitzt sich die Lage für
die Strecken den Fahrer zu in einem
gepanzerten Fahrzeug rückt ein
polnischer Sicherheitsdienst in
Begleitung des Militärs an er will sich
die LKW im Handstreich zurückholen
Ersatzfahrer hat er gleich mitgebracht
aber die Streitenden geben die LKW ihr
einziges Druckmittel nicht her
zwischen den Fronten die deutsche
Polizei
schließlich setzen sich die Streikenden
Fahrer durch der Spediteur und seine
Leute werden im Anschluss vorübergehend
festgenommen ihnen wird
Landfriedensbruch und Nötigung
vorgeworfen
Tage später beginnen Gespräche mit dem
Spediteur in einem leeren Hänger laufen
die Verhandlungen am Telefon die
Spedition ist der Auffassung sie habe
alles bezahlt wozu sie verpflichtet sei
die Gewerkschafter sehen das ganz anders
dann endlich der Durchbruch die Firma
gibt nach akzeptiert die Lohnforderung
aller Fahrer
[Applaus]
wir sind dankbar für die Unterstützung
in Deutschland von politisch
Verantwortlichen wie von Leuten aus der
Umgebung hier los
für kakabiri aus Georgien ein Festtag er
hat gehört dass in Deutschland
Lkw-Fahrer dringend gesucht werden
hier sind 60 leute nehmt doch die 60
Leute und gibt uns die Chance sagen wir
für drei Monate und wenn ihr zufrieden
seid mit der Arbeit dann nimmt uns
aber so leicht geht das nicht Fahrer wie
er müssen in Deutschland zuerst einen
140 stündigen Lehrgang durchlaufen in
Polen geht das unbürokratischer
[Musik]
Beamte der Verkehrspolizei sind bei
Bautzen auf der A4 unterwegs
lkw-kontrolle Ladungssicherung es kommt
anders eine Gefahrenstelle
Reifenteile auf der Autobahn hier müssen
sie handeln
lassen 300 Meter setzen sie auf dem
Standstreifen zurück daneben rauscht der
Verkehr
Einsatz für Tino Hausdorf
das ist natürlich eine akute Gefahr für
den Fahrverkehr und dann müssen wir
wirken also da können wir nicht dran
vorbeifahren dann müssen wir tatsächlich
direkt eingreifen
LKW voll beladen und schlecht gewartet
da sind Reifen Platzer vorprogrammiert
eine Gefahr für alle anderen
Verkehrsteilnehmer
alles gut nun zu ihrem eigentlichen Job
Lenkzeiten ladungs- und
Verkehrssicherheit überprüfen Sie
dieser Lastwagen kommt aus Lettland
Führerschein sehen
ein schneller Blick auf Bremsen und
Reifen in Ordnung der Fahrer hat 33
Paletten Deo geladen
genauso wie es in entsprechend den
Richtlinien ist also das sozusagen die
Ladung gut gesichert ist und auch bei
Gefahrenbremsung nicht verrutschen kann
ein spanischer LKW ist der nächste
der Fahrer ist auf dem Weg nach Polen 19
Tonnen Glas hat er auf dem Hänger noch
heute will er sein Ziel erreichen
eigentlich
[Musik]
die Ladungssicherung ist jetzt auf den
ersten Blick nicht so
überzeugend sage ich mal weil
letztendlich wird die Ladung nur über
ein ganz ganz geringen Winkel auf dem
Boden gepresst das ist alles ein wenig
unglücklich
haben sie selber geladen
mit dem Computer können die Polizisten
ausrechnen welche Kräfte auf diese
Ladung wirken und welche Sicherung dafür
vorgeschrieben ist
schnell steht das Ergebnis fest die
Sicherung ist mangelhaft also das Glas
ist hier oben gesichert mit mit Folien
das funktioniert aber der Ladungsträger
selbst auf dem Fahrzeug der den kann man
fast als ungesichert bezeichnen das ist
halt das Problem der Fahrer möchte
dennoch weiterfahren es sei ja nicht so
weit bis zum Ziel
das können wir so nicht machen und das
Ziel ist tatsächlich fast 400 km von
hier entfernt
die Firma des Fahrers muss jemanden
beauftragen der die Ladung vor Ort
richtig befestigt nach nur einer halben
Stunde ist ein Gabelstapler organisiert
zusätzliche Gummimatten sollen
verhindern dass die ganze Ladung
verrutscht der Fahrer sieht seinen
Wochenplan dahinschmelzen
ich muss heute noch nach Polen aber die
Stunden die ich hier verliere kann ich
die ganze Woche nicht aufholen
unglücklicherweise kontrollieren wir
genau immer die Kraftfahrer die in der
Regel ein wenig dafür können ja die
fahren an die Rampe die werden beladen
die haben dort einen gewissen Stress die
müssen die Ladungssicherung übernehmen
der Kraftfahrer ist das letzte Lied in
der Kette das ist halt tatsächlich ein
Problem die Kontrollen der Beamten sind
stichprobenhaft mehr geht nicht bei
jährlich 290 Millionen LKW Fahrten in
Deutschland
[Musik]
den Brenner hat er hinter sich
Trucker Udo Horn fährt durch Südtirol
das ist gut in Italien zu sein ich habe
mich der Lebensweise der Italiener
angepasst und
kann dadurch leichter entscheiden was
ich wann mache
er ist unterwegs zu seiner
entladestation in der Nähe von Florenz
fast jede Woche einmal Toskana und
zurück ich glaube ich habe in meinem
Leben mehr Zeit auf dem LKW verbracht
aber wenn ich nicht klar gebe hätte ich
schon aufgegeben
ein Leben in enger
meist allein
am späten Nachmittag nähert er sich
seinem Ziel einem kleinen Ort in der
Umgebung von Florenz
im Industriegebiet befindet sich die
Kartonfabrik dort darf er seinen LKW
parken nicht viele Unternehmen lassen
das zu
so
haben wir es geschafft
ich denke mal ja
alle Arbeiter hier haben schon
Feierabend so also ich kann morgen früh
abladen
und was heißt das
jetzt Feierabend ist
es gibt schönere Ecken
man kann sich nicht aussuchen
Fernseher aufbauen essen
und dann schlafen
meistens schlafe ich ja mal so ein
bisschen beim Fernsehen gucken ein aber
wenn ich dann wach werde dann gehe ich
ins Bett
und dann morgen früh geht es weiter in
alter Frische
[Musik]
hallo Deutschland
Oranienburg nördlich von Berlin bei der
Supermarktkette Rewe suchen Sie eine
Lösung für den Fahrermangel
4 Uhr morgens Frühschicht für LKW-Fahrer
Rainer Simon anders als im Fernverkehr
bewegt er sich in diesem Job nur in
einem kleinen Radius die Filialen die er
heute ansteuert befinden sich alle in
Brandenburg
ich bin ganz gerne zu Hause abends und
das hat sich so auch mit dem Job hier
ergeben und da bin ich auch ganz froh
drüber die zweite Schicht beginnt um 13
Uhr aber Rainer arbeitet lieber früh ja
weil der Verkehrs ruhiger morgens und
man hat danach Feierabend man kann
abschließen bei der Mittagsschicht ist
so wenn man da noch vorher was macht man
weiß immer ich muss dann los die Uhr
tickt ich muss zur Arbeit da kann man
nicht so abschalten
von hier aus werden alle Filialen in
Nordosten Deutschlands geliefert von
Rügen bis in den Süden Brandenburgs bis
zu 400 LKW Fahrten täglich sind dazu
notwendig
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen
wie geht's sehr gut heute geht's noch
keine Klima
zu seinen Fahrern hält Standortleiter
Matthias Menzel einen persönlichen
Kontakt Bindung zum Unternehmen durch
Wertschätzung die aktuelle Situation am
Arbeitsmarkt ist sehr angespannt gerade
was das Thema Fahrer angeht für viele
ist ja mittlerweile nicht nur das Geld
entscheidend aber auch die
Arbeitsbedingungen wie zum Beispiel
festes geregeltes Schichtsystem sind
halt essentiell für viele weil gerade
das Thema Beruf und Familie wofür wir
auch einstehen ist für die meisten sehr
sehr wichtig
er möchte noch mehr Fahrer einstellen
denn noch läuft ein großer Teil der
Lieferungen über Dienstleister die zu
Stoßzeiten hohe Preise fordern
40 Fahrer arbeiten hier schon direkt
angestellt bei der Supermarktkette aber
es sollen noch 30 mehr werden
[Musik]
also die Vorteile sind man ist sozial
abgesichert die Kollegen die das alles
das klappt alles die
Arbeitsmaterialien sind hier wirklich
top ja das gefällt mir
[Musik]
zwischen 6 und 8 Uhr muss Rainer die
Ware überall anliefern das erste Ziel
eine Filiale in Teltow
was passieren kann ist natürlich Stau
irgendwas am LKW oder ist irgendwas mal
umgekippt man hat ein Transportschein in
einer verzögert sich das natürlich alles
nach hinten raus aber die Zeitfenster
ist ja schon nicht schlecht also da hat
man schon ein bisschen spielen
mit Nacht und Überstunden Zuschlägen
konnte er auf rund 3.700 € brutto es ist
schon was besonderes es gibt nicht viele
für
das Gehalt bezahlen und schon gar nicht
speditionenbereich
die im Vergleich gute Bezahlung für die
Supermarktkette ein wichtiger Vorteil im
Kampf um die Ressource Lkw-Fahrer
nach einer Nacht im LKW beginnt in
Italien um 6.30 Uhr das Abladen der
altpapierrollen die Arbeitsbedingungen
von Udo sind hart wer ist es nicht
anders gewohnt
in der nächsten Fabrik wird er Fliesen
für Deutschland laden
König der Landstraße von Wien ich bin
kein Romantiker
ich bin da eher so der Realist
wegfahren wiederkommen fertig mir geht's
eigentlich nicht zu sagen
Lkw-Fahrer sie halten unsere Wirtschaft
im Laufen ohne sie würde unser Wohlstand
schwinden doch damit die Branche wieder
attraktiver wird sind dringend neue
Ideen gefragt
[Musik]